[Music]
that's beautiful
brandon tell what you think
um okay i guess
brendan tell me tell me
[Music]
now i think i know why the grooms
normally don't come dress shopping with
the brides to be
because i don't think that they really
have that
wow this is so cool this is so exciting
feeling the way that i guess women do
it's definitely a girl thing
sure yes brandon say bye bye she needs
to go
yes oh okay all right bye-bye
so what do you think uh you think she
liked that one best
i like that one
it's just different style i ready
oh here she comes this is the one of the
last ones we pulled over here
it's a little bit flatter she should be
able to dance in that one
[Music]
you like that one you like that one
brendan what kind do you like more uh
the last one brandon plays more emoji
because you're like
doll you see it's like fine it's
fine they're all nice
i like more first
talk what what please stop
what do you want what what what do you
like talk about which i
said what i liked
random i just like that dress more
same reason i might like a coupe versus
a sedan
i think julia wants me to be like the
one you picked that's my favorite dress
but
she told me to be honest beforehand and
that's what i'm doing it's not my
favorite
you like this one though oh no i like
all of them i mean
they're all nice i don't like yours i
just no i like the first one
i like all of them i know describing i
would have told you
i know this happened i say brendan
please
don't say like i like this i like this
too i like this too
brandon not like talk with me about what
i want how i feel
and him not happy about nothing and like
he must show me like
what he wants he was out of his element
he had no clue what to even try and do
to help
you